welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and remember illuminati strange the
doctor strange variant from the 838
pizza papa universe that got a stern
talking to by one black agar boltagon
yeah what if i told you that he was
still actually very much alive and evil
what if a weird man on the internet told
you that doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness hid an incredibly
clever and subtle hint that 838 strange
himself will be back in doctor strange 3
as a villain how they make you feel on
the inside my nerd babies well let me
show you how he did that real quick
because it's actually quite clever but
before i show you that let me show you
some cool shirts over at
newrockstarsmerch.com because we have a
new latest obsession shirt inspired by
miss marvel called cosmic daydream but
it's not gonna last forever so be sure
to pick that up over at new rockstars
birch.com along with all of our other
amazing nerd gear alright gang join me
will you for we about to go take a trip
on our favorite rocket ship to the
beautifully vibrant world of titan look
at all those crops specifically the
version of titan from professor xavier's
mind projection in multiverse of madness
where 616 doctor strange is shown the
supposed fate of his 838 variant the
illuminati doctor strange who
accidentally caused the early
termination of another universe through
obsessive dreamwalking with the darkhold
he turned to the darkhold began
dreamwalking
in hopes that our salvation might lie in
the multiverse it didn't but he kept
doing it anyway you our friend
had caused the annihilation of another
universe because as that flashback opens
we can all clearly see a very murdered
thanos with his thanos copter ass sword
plunged right into the center of his
chest by the illuminati however what
people fail to notice here is that
probably the most important detail in
this scene is right on thanos's cold ass
purple palm that's right everybody the
infinity gauntlet because if you use
your beautiful nerd baby eyes you will
be able to see but there is actually one
infinity stone unaccounted for count
with me speculation nation because we
have the soul stone the reality stone
the space stone and the power stone and
of course everybody knows that the mine
stone in the middle is with vision on
earth and that thanos himself would save
that silly little robot apocalypse
starting stone for last meaning that the
only stone that is not accounted for
here is of course the infinity stone
that doctor strange loves the most the
time stone now why is this important
well you do remember a certain doctor
strange from doctor strange one don't
you the same doctor strange who used the
time stone to die over and over and over
again while facing dormammu in the dark
dimension and the very same doctor
strange who would then later on hide the
time stone in a little gravity bubble of
space time while wearing a fake eye of
agamotto to trick thanos in infinity war
now because we see that thanos was
defeated on titan in the earth 838
universe it means that earth 838 doctor
strange most likely did not need to
reveal his secret hiding spot because
unlike the main mcu universe in 616
steven did not have to remove the time
stone from a secret little hiding spot
in the middle of the air in order to
save tony stark's life because the
illuminati got the job done on titan and
thus the illuminati team most likely had
no idea where dr strange's time stone
even was or possibly even that doctor
strange had the time infinity stone in
the first place this video is brought to
you by the ridge the ridge wallet is
light sleek and industrial and it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky old old school
wallets that make you look like you're
smuggling an 80s car phone in your back
pocket it's ridiculous check this out
nice and sleek there are over three
colors and styles including carbon fiber
and bird's titanium and it holds up to
12 cards and still has room for cash in
the back and every ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and that lets
you test drive it for 45 days and send
it back for a full refund if you don't
love it which you will and the wallets
have over forty thousand five star
reviews and it's made with rfid blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pickpocketers and they also have
other cool products like this commuter
backpack it's weatherproof and great for
toting around a laptop and this month
marks nine years since the ridge started
and they're celebrating with a special
sale so get 15 off today with free
worldwide shipping and free returns by
going to ridge.com new rockstars that's
ridge.com new rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in this
video's description we thank ridge again
for sponsoring this video basically i'm
saying all of this just to say that i
believe that 838 doctor strange is
faking his death specifically by using
the time stone to reverse his brutal
obliteration at the lips of black bolt
much like he did with his obliteration
at the lips of one mamamoo
[Music]
because i believe that there is one
really important thing that we've got to
remember in regards to this version of
doctor strange illuminati doctor strange
was incredibly corrupted by the darkhold
i mean look at those freaking fingertips
man black like agathas and we learned
from mr fantastic himself that doctor
strange developed a severe addiction to
the darkhold while trying to find ways
to defeat the mad titan i mean it's the
reason why he was put to death by his
friends on the illuminati after all like
they didn't kill him just because they
were mad at him for destroying that one
universe the illuminati needed to kill
doctor strange much like agatha's mom
and the coven at salem needed to kill
agatha harkness because both parties
knew that the darkhold was all
corrupting and that the darkhold has a
plan of its own to fill the universe
with darkness both agatha's bomb and the
illuminati knew that once you spend at
least a little bit of time with that
evil dictionary of darkness you were
going to become a dark pawn of its
perilous pages with little hope of
redemption and a high chance of filling
the universe with the dark chaos magic
within the dark hold something that i
suspect 838 doctor strange did with that
variant to flood that variant's universe
with darkness thus turning that innocent
doctor strange variant into the dreaded
dormammu himself which is why benedict
cumberbatch voices him in doctor strange
one it's because dermamu is probably a
variant of doctor strange which is of
course why we see clea at the very end
of multiverse of madness heading back
into the dark dimension to fix that very
incursion that caused the creation of
the dark dimension in the first place
clia needs doctor strange to heal dr
strange but anyways basically what i'm
saying here about this 838 doctor
strange is that the darkhold had too
dang strong of a hold on this doctor
strange mind and you can even tell this
by just the way the illuminati and
christine palmer talk about this 838
strange like that dude went way too far
and was way too untrustworthy and much
like agatha harkness resisted her own
execution i believe that illuminati
doctor strange faked his own death as
soon as reed richards portaled all those
people off of titan by completely
reversing his atomic annihilation
through the use of the time stone
something that he has done before and
probably has way more experience doing
by the time of infinity war as he would
have had years studying the time stone
by that point but that is it everybody
do not believe the lies in the
propaganda 838 doctor strange is alive
and he's coming back he's coming for you
and that is why i believe that 838
doctor strange is still alive and is
plotting something very very nefarious
for the mcu but let us know what you
guys think in the comment section below
but yeah thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] and
insane theories but most importantly you
can follow new rockstars wherever we are
on social media and when you do on
youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video which is basically every day you
don't want to miss any and of course hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com to buy all of
our amazing shirts they're so amazingly
designed especially our cosmic daydream
shirt inspired by miss marvel that is
going away very soon but again thank you
guys so much for watching this video i
love you guys so much please stay safe
and love each other and i'll see you
guys next time bye
[Music]
you